well what was Jim Carrey like though if
you've heard if you don't know die I'm
dying up here it's produced by Jim
Carrey yes if you if you know that
phrase when someone says don't meet your
heroes because they'll let you down yeah
you know that phrase yeah it's the exact
opposite with him cool and I mean that
wholeheartedly
it was the first person that I met when
I when I that I grew up like admiring to
a level of like you know creepiness yeah
you like emulated him in every way and
then when I met him it was like he lived
up to all the things that I had kind of
hoped yeah yeah yeah he was nice sweet
smart he's Coast kind and very [ __ ] very
[ __ ] funny
unapologetically funny and ever and he's
not doing it to put on a show do you
know what I mean like he's I never once
it I feel like Jim was like trying to
but do it for the crowd you know I mean
no not it he was just his way of
thinking is inherently unique and funny
and he was the [ __ ] man I think he's you
know I think he's the best and he
contributed so many stories to the show
which is why I think it's a special show
like a lot of the stories on the show
that you watch or his real-life dude
like two characters live in a closet in
the pilot he lived in the closet was
Holly we yeah yeah yeah you know like
all these like little weird stories I
don't want to give away any the
storylines but there's a lot of [ __ ]
that happens in the show that if it
seems like a pretty unique thing it's
probably from him if you watch a show
and you're like did that really happen
I bet you it's his store a storyline
that he had but see he comes from the
eighties right the late 80s where well
late 1770s yeah yeah lates everybody was
there during the eighties yes all right
and that was the first real heyday Toto
Comedy Store right so then you know he
would go up like with Damon Wayans and
all those guys at the end of the night
and everyone was there like the lineups
were stacked it was insane and it was a
magical place to be and then what I
started in the 90s it completely died
everyone on the line of his people that
we'll never see on TV and it was
terrible and I feel like now just by
being a part of those line ups and stuff
I mean I've got I'm back on shows
because I feel like I'm reaping the
benefits generally around what the
comedy stores fortune
really yeah it's like the waiting game
though you know I mean like your talent
never went away you were always just as
talented yeah if not more talented now
you're welcome
and and and yes it is a it's a it's a
cyclical thing technical thing I think
now that it's come back people that are
talented are getting recognized more
because of that place why but for years
there's guys that were super talented
that the industry didn't give a [ __ ]
about it's also cuz dude I mean and I
don't I hope this isn't true but I'd I
hope this big bubble doesn't pop but
comedy bubble is so big right now like
everyone is like sucking comedy off like
every there's a special every week it's
like it's it's I don't know if it's too
much
a little saturated it's a lot area I
love it because we're definitely getting
some comeuppance but it's it's a
shitload but you know what doing all
those things that are hot not I've been
in it for over 20 years
no it's way more than 20 I've had years
of just nothingness and I just you know
the real goal is not to quit I'm just
gonna stay in it and if it happens you
know I mean you just gotta I want to
stay in the water but when you say it
happens it already happen don't you
think it's you know it's not happened
for me it's happening it hasn't happened
for me it's happening continually it may
or may not perspective of someone who
wants to even try to do calm I
understand that but I understand but see
with that argument never sits well with
me because I've made choices and I know
my abilities it doesn't [ __ ] okay let's
put it like this real you're not doing
stand-up right now in this energy
alternate you in another universe yeah
what what are you doing
dead dead probably okay yeah but so it's
not happening
yeah I know what you're saying now with
that argument is is that I was just
walking down the street yeah and
somebody came up to me and said hey I'm
mr. Hollywood you want to be on chose
Steve Hollywood or Dave holiday yes
you've such a day's a dick it's too jewy
for me but no no what I'm well know what
I'm say but what the truth though is is
that people go yeah you should be
grateful for what you have you do
killing it
I'm just no what are you saying that
what I'm saying is I know that I
wouldn't be in a position in my life
that I'm at right now which I feel very
grateful for if I was not doing stand-up
right okay so miserable
of course yeah and you did everything
you want you did but I'm just saying
you've already made it because you're
making a life doing exactly what you
were supposed to do you were born to be
an entertainer right okay yeah it always
straddles the line between in gratitude
or humility I can never quite tell with
him I think it comes more from the
humility side of it though where it's a
guilt it's like this creates like a
guilt use a guilt it's guilt yeah look
at the way you live and look at the
things that you have and not not not not
not monetary I'm talking about us look
at the life that you have I'm just
saying how many of you think you would
have this life if you didn't do what you
did I'm gonna show you something right
now and I'll tell you why you and I make
noodles in some little shop somewhere
hurry gates
hurry game yeah welcome to Prairie gate
noodle would be making noodle soup no
all I'm saying is I think when someone
says to me here you know why I think
like this Bobby for real yeah when
someone back home from Chicago when like
a not a friend but like someone with a
high school with or something and they
run into me somewhere in there like dude
I [ __ ] I hope you make it dude
that reira Minds me that it's like I've
already [ __ ] I pay my life I pay my
life by doing the thing that I like
right and I made it when I [ __ ] I'll
tell you when I made it quote-unquote in
my brain is the day that I quit my
[ __ ] day job on their friggin to like
I cried and laughed and I was like manic
where were you I was in an office on
Wilshire Boulevard working for this
music company like a [ __ ] like a desk
[ __ ] you know I was a desk [ __ ] yeah I
got the phone call that I booked this
like Hosty job that I knew was just
enough money for one year to make to let
me quit you know and it was a guaranteed
year and a woman called me to tell me I
booked the thing and I'm not I'm not
exaggerating I threw the phone I threw
the phone and I ran down the stairwell
the whole time I fairway I ran
I ran on stairwell and I'm not I'm not
exaggerating on Wilshire across from
like where the e building is or whatever
about the carpets I ran all the way down
to Highland I ran I just kept running
because I was like laughing and it was
like it was so exciting I was like I
quit I get to quit I get the [ __ ]
quit [ __ ] it was so good to me and I
walked right back you're right Andrew I
know all right but I'm gonna tell you
why you're wrong okay after that story
high school in Poway high school and on
Facebook someone said someone got
inducted into their Hall of Fame
oh my [ __ ] you know what the [ __ ] I'm
saying yes go home gay and I'm not in it
in the Hall of Fame you want to be in
the Poway yeah
you know who's in it who I'll show you
who Matthew fy'y who's that I don't know
no he's he's a doctor and he is also a
violinist Oh Matthew fine yeah yeah yeah
David gödel David goda he's a golf goof
off golf golf I know he's he made
science and business is he part of the
golf goof-off coalition what my point is
not made it until I'm in this Hall of
Fame look at me look at me yeah
look at me yeah okay but you know what
he I stand by my point
what did I do you know what he did you
know what this [ __ ] asked what I said
contacted the high school know some guy
somebody had written what no Bobby Lee
so and so and like tagged him in it
right true and so some guy then oh yeah
what about Hector Maldonado [ __ ] he's a
guitarist for some reason that kid was
always a sweetheart and a talented
player and then Hector Maldonado writes
thanks Norah kind of you to say Bobby
you wanted to reply to the whole post
yeah but I didn't reply to that boy
Maldonado isn't what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] he reads it back to me and
he goes oh god I put it on the wrong
slot how do you delete it so he's yeah
we're scrambling I'm sweating did MALDI
ever find out I don't know I think we
was on for 5 min oh my god well here's
it now he's gonna hear it now I don't
care now because now he knows it was a
mistake that's right I'm not saying heck
I'm alone I don't have ever heard of you
I'm sure you're famous but great
guitarist I was on a national TV show
for eight years and I'm on national TV
matter but a bunch of movies it's fine
I'm sure your grosso plays the piano you
also played camera also so I can do what
you do by doing the guitar is not a
credit you know plays a guitar guys in
college but anyway I'm sure you're great
but I was saying Poway hurts yeah it
hurts me but I may never get in it but
that's my goal now we end with our shows
what time were we out now over an hour
yeah because he's so good why would we
end this we have to end it yo you do guy
who didn't make it to the Poway Hall of
famous tonk Tom DeLonge from blink 182
yeah Tom dude that guy's not on there
now then how can you feel bad about not
being on I know that I'm saying I'm
making a poor I'm making a cage you're
proving my for me the launch is your
doing right and Stephanie Seymour I
think she should be on it too totally
Stephanie Seymour like GNR I'm a
supermodel yeah well got a lover go to
high school you know why I'll do mine
you know why I'll never be on my BA
because I'm not anybody right now but
I'll never be on it because everyone
that's on it is Oh is a world-class
athlete I went to school with like nine
pro football players two Olympians they
would [ __ ] never put me at they were
no amazing athletes and then goofball
know who fall down land on that lap no
stop okay pro athletes people that were
played in this super but I don't give a
[ __ ] because let me say this alright
what that's eight years of a career in
pro athlete life yeah ten years maybe
yeah most of them don't win big trophies
you have no famous people from my school
I went to reject high school but we did
have the son of do you guys knew who
Darryl Strawberry is Oh horse his son
went to my high school a saving grace he
also loved cocaine like his father know
he was a good athlete and he but not in
baseball and basketball
see yeah well because he was really tall
right
that's like um imagine what Rihanna's
from Barbados right like turtles yeah
imagine that high school how annoying
that is no one's on that Hall of Fame
and no one will ever get on it for her
yeah well she might even get in it's
like Polly hi
that's true if Poway high holds true to
their [ __ ] [ __ ] standards but do
you know why they're not gonna ever
nominate me because that's how I know I
graduated from that school for years but
the reason why is because all these guys
are outstanding in their community
they're good guys what do you mean
you're like a night guy I know but in
high school I went to three rehabs I got
kicked out twice so but I still
graduated from that I came back and I
get it
but I don't think that I'm the kind of
image they want to put out there either
even even come along so I think that
that's the reason why all these guys are
shirt Tucker's maybe both of you guys
didn't go actually graduate I think way
more in my [ __ ] case over here did
you have an empty diploma and oh I have
it right here I [ __ ] [ __ ] oh you
have to go [ __ ] [ __ ] I've got a
[ __ ] diploma in my [ __ ] graduation
you hadn't actually graduated yeah I
[ __ ] walked a line [ __ ] you got an
empty diploma right yes often
circumstance like okay is probably high
like I said is it a is it a notable
school oh yeah say it like every
wrestling I think we're like big and
wrestling you want to be in the
wrestling schools role yeah yeah I was
on the team but my view were yeah yeah
why would I do I was I was on the
[ __ ] tennis team - why when I tell
sit with you are you so weak and
malleable why does your a weight
different weight class I know so you're
20 years younger than I am it's I think
it's like a man thing more than anything
you know what yeah do you know what it
is me a man yeah versus